Ok, it's Mark Wiens here, I'm in Varanasi,
India.
It's about seven am and I'm taking a morning
boat ride and the whole city is sort of waking
up, but there's a lot of fog.
Every morning has fog?
Almost, yes, but sometimes not fog, sometimes.
Ok.
What is your name?
My name is Mark.
Ponkarch, ok, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
But one of the best ways to explore Varanasi
is just on foot walking along the river on
these ghats, and there are multiple, many
many ghats along the river.
And a ghat is like a series of steps that
leads down to the river.
So it makes a really great place to walk around.
It's peaceful, yet at the same time it's mystical,
it's really magical as well.
Hey it's Mark Wiens here and I am in Varanasi,
India, at the main ghat, and there's always
something exciting going down here.
You can see over here today there's like a
mass wedding going on.
One of the best ways to explore Varanasi is
by walking through the narrow alleyways, umm,
these alleyways are all over near the Ganges
river, and it's a maze, but it's filled with
shops, there's temples, little shrines, there's
restaurants and street food, but it's just
an always entertaining area to walk around
with many many people and just one of the
joys of visiting Varanasi is just to explore
these back alleys.
Mmm, it's so hot and fresh!
Green peas, and there's some onions and spices
on top, and you eat it with a leaf in a leaf.
Oh yah!
Malaiyo it's called, it's like a, wow
it's very foamy, wow, it's surprisingly delicious.